we just think this thing through let me
know if I'm going too fast for you why
would anyone kill a pizza delivery man
and how good a gun man know who he was
gonna kill it doesn't make any sense
that's very good you got your speech
ready for the superintendent there was a
murder in my constituency we heard
gunfire it's a Muslim killing right can
we just say was a human being it was
shot down on a British street they're
trying to take everything from us it's a
way of life they want to destroy we
believe your brother was killed
deliberately because he knows something
Sam Spencer my five we believe there's a
national security dimension
they want your information but they
don't want to give up any of this
there are servile to everyone and we
control Network people no longer believe
in institutions and it's for exactly the
reasons you're giving me none it comes
down to people I need names we're gonna
have to trade you and I you're gambling
killing these are people's lives
my father had an interesting view
he said if you left any institution
without business meant you've beaten it
if you were richer the institution at
one
we're being offered a chance to put
something right
[Music]
you
you